according to our reporting a London  Court has granted the flash crash trader  and this is Anna vendor Singh sarao  who's 36 years old conditional bail we  don't know the amount just yet but this  is the only headline we have to work  with here of course no vendors sing  Sorrell as you mentioned is accused of  helping cause the flash crash back can  may have 2010 in which the dow jones  industrial average and other indexes  here in the US plunged in seconds the  dow for instance losing a thousand  points over the course of a couple of  seconds on that afternoon before  recovering just as quickly sang Sorrell  has said that he will fight efforts to  extradite him to face these charges in  the US but we will keep you posted on  any developments including the dollar  amount of this conditional bail that the  london court reportedly has granted him